Howdy, Mark.
What you got going on there?
>> Oh, you know,
just working Android Studio.
Why are you wearing-
>> Android Studio?
Why you lily livered son of a droid.
Real code cowboys build
from the command line.
Just EMAX, ADB, and Gradle.
That's all I need to
build an Android app.
>> But there's code completion and
automatic refactoring.
>> Who even knows what's going on
inside one of them fancy city IDEs?
Could be anything happening
in the build process.
Not like good, old, honest,
hard working Gradle.
>> Android Studio doesn't
even use an internal builder.
What did you say, now?
>> Android Studio delegates its
entire build process to Gradle.
There's nothing magic happening.
>> Whoa, that's super-cool.
[COUGH] I mean.
Really now?
So, you're saying that I
could use Android Studio for
all them fancy code-completion features,
and still wrangle my build process?
>> Yeah, exactly.
See, look, I can pull up
my terminal Android Studio,
run my Gradle build task, and see.
>> Oh my.
All them fancy features, and
it's just Gradle under the saddle.
I reckon I got some thinking to do.
Thanks for the tip, partner.